[Music]
foreign
do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere else
you have the power to create your own
future you can be anything you can do
anything
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats understuffed actually for
greater posability we're professionals
we're giving the people what they need
[Music]
did you see the latest numbers we broke
the entire internet
thing or you go home
[Music]
I would tell you he did it all
which it says craziness believing the
stuffed animals are gold
do you see the truck crash
insane poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together they have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary's been reduced
75 yeah I'm just doing what's necessary
you know running the real actual
business over here
my life is this company can I see where
it's going
there are signs of real trouble genius
is one percent inspiration 99
presentation
that's not how the saying goes
[Music]
everything good that's happened to me is
because of you guys we are bonded
forever
[Music]
they're poisoning him
countless times
[Music]
I have our perfect Partners lined up
Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is that
[Music]
I'm gonna go
is
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out
[Music]
foreign